i got a bunch of questions for you i'll
start with congrats on the movie
um so i'm if you could get the financing
for anything
tomorrow any project you want to make
what would you make and why
that's a great question
i would love to make a western you know
from the top of my head it's either
going to be a western or a 70s heist
movie which
i just finished writing but there's
something about me that itches and wants
to go back to this role that we've just
built
and work again with this amazing cast
so i don't know how i can accommodate
all these
ideas and desires maybe it's going to be
another genre blender where
all these amazing talented actors are
gonna be in a western or something
i i would like that i i say yes
it's greenlit yes got it
i'll send you book and we'll get that up
and running
right exactly uh i definitely have the
power for that um
one of the things that i found
interesting is that all the characters
in the film have a different color
choice
can you sort of talk about uh how you
figured out which color for each
character
do you ever was it ever going to be
other things i have to admit
first of all casting this amazing
talented group of
actresses was beyond my wildest dreams i
mean lina and karen were
the first dude to join me it was already
a perfect cast
then having angela michelle carla
it was just beyond my wildest dreams and
with that
comes a lot of responsibility you want
to make them a unit you want to
also give them you know individual
um layers so you can separate them and
understand them and it was always from
the beginning the idea of creating
their correlation between their the way
they look
to their room to their signature room
so we we wanted angela with the blue
outfits to be the ocean room as a kind
of a camouflage
and michelle to fit in the
in the forest room with kind of a
camouflage so it was
both a way to give them individuality
but also
to get them to look like a unit almost
like the uniforms
but i didn't want the uniforms to feel
mundane but they still feel like oh wait
a minute i can i can see that they're
all
kind of the same genre of dress code but
very very with a very strong emphasis on
their individuality
uh one of the things about this is that
you you had this amazing cast right
at what day on set were you like i
cannot believe i'm directing michelle
and she's listening to what i have to
say and then doing it
it happened before before the first day
of shooting actually i remember
she came to us on her way to avatar
i think she was shooting avatars she
came for i think a day
just to put you know bring her up to
speed and we were working on the diner
shots
so this is a very complicated shot the
one
and we've been working on it for quite
some time i think it was two weeks
getting the stunt people to do it the
right way and
and lina is there and then michelle
comes in
and does it in like 10 minutes she just
nailed it like the
second take and like yeah that's how
it's going to be like
we have michelle yao in our movie and
with that coming a lot of responsibility
and i remember a week before we started
shooting i saw a movie i
do not remember what movie it was i
think if i'll go back maybe i'll find
that screening in this
you know on the web but i remember
seeing the trailers
and seeing the trailers i looked to
erode my core right and i told him
i'm actually doing one of this in a week
from now
with the dream cast and i had to pinch
myself
it was basically a dream come true
absolutely um i definitely want to talk
about that tracking shot
it is awesome it is for people that will
see the movie it's slow motion
you're tracking with all the characters
you stunt people you it's a
crazy shot at what point did the
producers say to you
really wait what
from the get-go it's like oh really
this is what we're gonna do do you
honestly but i think when
i explained to them and we talked about
it a lot that
you have this great big set piece
almost like a sem packing by wild bunch
set piece at the library
you know going in a place of glory it's
big it's loud it's
you know it's all the ladies working
together
it's really hard to top that in volume
and i didn't want to
i wanted to create something more poetic
so more emotional
for obvious reasons which i'm sure we
don't want to spoil
and the way to achieve that was through
this almost
poem this slow-mo almost renaissance
like
still like a an image a photograph
locked in time and i think very fast we
did
very quickly we did um some mock-ups
with the stun people and card boxes just
to get a feeling of how it's going to
look like and it was already good
then and there and i think by that point
where we saw it with card boxes and
stunned people
and shot on an iphone or with a camera
we realized okay this is going to be
very special and it's ruth you know all
the investments in it and
sure enough we had only four takes every
time we had to reset it took an hour and
a half it was very close space
20 stun people all the cars in you know
in summer
in berlin all because it's slo-mo
all the lights are up to probably
200 percent more so it was
it was a nightmare but we all felt it
was worth it and it was actually one of
the more rewarding
days we ever had yeah that shot's
amazing
um so you have a few shots that are in
focus on the left and right side of the
frame
and i kept to me i was like is this like
an homage to speed racer almost
when they did the whole frame in in
focus
was that your motivation or was it just
like i just want to keep everything in
focus
from from the get-go i mean i've i had a
pleasure of working with uh
michael cersein the legendary dops shot
midnight express alan parker's movies
coron movies metrics latest
um planets of the apes trilogy and
immediately i think from the from the
get-go i told him this is going to be
old-school wildlands you see everything
you know i want to take it a step back
i'm not interested in that handled
kind of like shaky feeling i want the
audience to to understand the geography
to feel
to be completely submerged in that
feeling and
that was that was the initial idea and
i'm i'm really happy it worked that way
because
it feels a little bit more classical in
a way than
you know maybe they shoot movies these
days yeah i'm not a fan of the super
fast cuts but that's just me
um i gotta stop there i'm just gonna say
congrats on the movie i hope you're
doing something again very soon
thank you for your time thank you
stephen